[Musik]
die Olivenbäume werden übrigens auch
nicht gespritzt als es wirklich alles
super natürlich um aber trotzdem
Schädlinge wegzuhalten hat man hier
diese Flaschen aufgehängt und zwar sind
in dieser Flasche ferromone drin es gibt
nämlich die berühmt berüchtigte Oliven
Fliege und die frisst sich wirklich in
die Olive rein zerstört zum einen die
Geschmacksstoffe und zum anderen frisst
ihr natürlich auch die Polyphenole raus
deswegen sind hier Pheromone drin die
Weibchen also die Fliegen Weibchen
werden damit erst gar nicht angelockt
die bleiben schön weg und die Männchen
die fliegen da rein und werden so
bekämpft sowie in der Natur dass die
Weibchen einfach schlau sind und die
Gefahr wittern und wegbleiben und die
Männer die tappen leider in die Pfanne
[Musik]